let's do a little bit of fact-checking
of Donald Trump Donald Trump existing in
a fantasy world in that second
presidential debate yesterday I told you
about how just embarrassingly uh
clueless Donald Trump was on all issues
in in losing in tone and losing in
substance is really embarrassing let's
fact check just some of the fantasy
world nonsense of Trump from the second
presidential debate let's I'll just
randomly pick there there's probably 40
or 50 of these I'm just gonna do five
with you today here's a first claim from
Trump from the debate to talk about
Trump claimed healthcare is going up by
numbers that are astronomical
sixty-eight percent fifty-nine percent
in 71 percent the truth is according to
the Kaiser Family Foundation which
monitors exactly these types of issues
that health insurance premiums for
families rose an average of three
percent last year Trump just lying
making it up it's bogus how about
Obamacare Donald Trump claimed that
Obamacare is a disaster you know it we
all know it it is going up at numbers
that nobody has ever seen worldwide
nobody has ever seen numbers like this
for health care it is only getting worse
in 17 it implodes by itself you sort of
have to really make an effort to even
understand what on earth Trump is
talking about there but the truth is
that Obamacare has actually reduced the
uninsured rate to an all-time low of
nine percent and extended coverage to 20
million people a Trump accused Hillary
Clinton of wanting single-payer
healthcare Trump saying but she wants to
go to single-payer the truth is that
Hillary Clinton does not support
single-payer she supports exam expanding
Medicare the people 55 and over I wish
Hillary Clinton wanted single-payer
health care unfortunately she doesn't
and then how about those Syrian refugees
Donald Trump claimed during the second
debate that hundreds of thousands of
people coming in from Syria when we know
nothing about them we know nothing about
their values and we know nothing about
their love for our country the truth is
that the u.s. is only accepted about
10,000 Syrian refugees in the most
recent fiscal year we actually know a
lot about them in the US has one of the
most rigorous screening systems
for refugees in the world last one just
for kicks Trump on his Russia
relationship Trump claiming I don't deal
there I have no businesses there and
have no loans from Russia the truth is
Trump has been trying to do business
with Russia since the 1980s he looked at
hotel development in the 90s he tried a
project in 2008 and he told the real
estate publication just three years ago
that the Russian market is attracted to
me I have a great relationship with many
Russians and almost all of the oligarchs
were in the room lies lies and endless
lies with Donald Trump and too many of
his supporters are none the wiser and I
I know guys that it's almost quaint to
say hey Trump lied people should be
scared about that because he's lying
about demonstrably untrue things he's
made fun of disabled people he's
recommended sex tapes on Twitter [ __ ]
gate the entire thing at this point
Rachel I don't think a lie about
Obamacare is gonna lose Trump any
supporters is it no it's not but he's so
oriented towards kind of seizing what he
wants as opposed to kind of connecting
with people and the citizens of America
yeah so that's kind of what I feel like
makes it pathological yeah and and
speaking of connecting with people Pat
when in when in that second debate town
hall forum at hillary clinton was asked
a question she would walk over stand in
front of the person look at them and
talk to them where's Donald Trump it was
almost like he didn't understand that it
was a town hall you just could not
connect with anybody I don't know if
that's what you wanted to comment on but
that was my impression I thought he
looked to moralize I thought he looked
tired about that debate and you know the
lies that we just put forward on the
screen there it'd be a lot of it stems
from the fact that he's not prepared
right so he's just talking in these you
knows talking points and just kind of uh
sort of that rating whatever comes yeah
not actually going into the numbers you
can cherry-pick information that would
support his claims but he's not doing
that it's almost like he says I mean
Obamacare I don't know it must have gone
up insanely in terms of what things cost
I'll just throw out numbers like 68 and
it just has no connection to any
preparation or data that the guys ever
seen and I think you're absolutely right
that a lot of it is lack of preparation
I've talked about how people of all ages
but particularly Millennials are owning
cars less and participating more in the
sharing economy and one of the more
popular options is zip car which gets
you a car when you want it when you need
it they offer all sorts of cars SUVs
hybrids whatever you need it includes
insurance and it includes gas you just
pay for the time that you actually use
the car and you can reserve the car
online from your smartphone over the
phone then you unlock it with your
zipcard each car share member reduces
their personal co2 emissions by between
1100 and 1,600 pounds per year for our
audience zipcar is offering $25 a free
driving credit if you sign up at joined
zipcar dot-com / David support our show
reduce your carbon emissions and you're
spending on cars sign up at join zipcar
dot-com / David